hello freak [ __ ] you should step back
and this is a narrative that gets
repeated over and over again in the
social justice warrior culture this idea
that you should just step back and let
these others talk because they
understand is long yeah and the others
are always other group mates right and
somehow their their discourse is to be
privileged in reverse because
hypothetically they're a member of an
oppressed class right course and you can
multiply the numbers of oppressed
classes at nauseam which is another part
of the problem
yeah like the idea is that in giving
them privilege because they have been
marginalized you will balance things out
you'll somehow another reverse this yeah
yeah but and that's another example of
the class-based guilt idea you know it's
it doesn't seem to me self-evident that
I'm to blame for slavery for example I
mean being a Canadian it's a slightly
different situation I suppose but the
the idea that as the member as a member
of a culture that you're somehow
responsible for the past sins of that
culture let's say it it's a very very
anti Western ethos it goes along with
this idea of class guilt because your
group membership is the most important
thing if your group at some point in the
past did something reprehensible which
of course every group has done that's
for sure then you are de facto
responsible in the present for that how
do you think we got to this point where
people are repeating these patterns that
were ultimately incredibly unsuccessful
and dangerous and deadly in the past
like Marxism for example like people
proudly proclaim themselves as having
Marxist ideology one five one in five
social scientists claims to be a Marxist
kind of owner I understand the history
what would once you fill people in on
how that went bad well the estimates
vary but in the Soviet Union between
1919 and 1959 somewhere between thirty
and fifty million people were killed in
internal repression alone so that's
pretty bad and then and in China which
was operating under exactly the same
principles might have been up to a
hundred million killed during Mao's time
and of course Mao was still revered in
China appallingly enough and Vietnam in
Cambodia and wherever these ideas were
implemented
Cuba wherever these ideas were
implemented the result was absolute
mayhem absolute mayhem and I think what
happened is that the Marxist ideas are
actually quite attractive if you're an
intellectual and if you're I would say
if you're tilted towards compassion from
a personality perspective because
they're based on doctrines like from
from each according to his ability to
each according to his need and the idea
that you should fulfill people's needs
or that society should fulfill people's
needs is on the surface of it an
attractive idea of course the problem is
who gets to define the needs and who
gets to define the abilities and that
really is a big problem and well and
then those ideas were put into practice
first in the Soviet Union and Alexander
Solzhenitsyn who wrote the Gulag
Archipelago did a very lovely job of
detailing in in horrifying detail how
those initial doctrines were transformed
into legislation and then how those
legislation was transformed into endless
genocide essentially and almost
destroyed the world let's not forget
that partly with partly with the help of
Castro who just died the the doctrines
when when put into proxy in into into
actual practice where murderous
instantaneously now what happened there
were always apologists for the left in
the West especially in France especially
among the French intellectuals
especially in the late 1960s and then
when all of the information about what
was happening is in the Soviet Union
came flooding forward and that
culminated say in 19 Boat 1973 when
Solzhenitsyn's book was published the
French intellectuals changed their tune
instead of agitating on a part of the
working class which was which allied
them with murderous Marxists they
switched and and started to talk about
power and and talk about a group
identity it was like a sleight of hand
the underlying pathological philosophy
remained exactly the same but the
surface nomenclature changed and that
became very attractive and at the same
time the Soviet Union dissolved and so
one of the problems I think we have now
a perverse problem is that these Marxist
ideas are very attractive to
compassionate intellectuals and we don't
have good bad examples like the Soviet
Union around that everybody can point to
and go yeah yeah well that sounds good
but you know what about the murderous
death camps and the millions of people
who are suffering we still have North
Korea but you know people treat North
Korea like it's a joke instead of like
it's an exemplar of a pathological
system and people have no historical
memory like my students and that's
partly because they're taught so badly
in schools is they have no idea what
happened in the Soviet Union they have
absolutely no idea they know a little
bit about the second world war maybe and
of course people generally know about
the Holocaust but they have no idea what
happened in the Soviet Union so they
have no idea where these ideas could
lead and and as and the universities and
the high schools are so full of people
who are radically left-leaning that
they're never taught any the students
are never taught any proper history you
know they're taught about the evils of
capitalism and you know I mean it's not
like it's not like any system is perfect
but there's difference between imperfect
and and consciously murderous I think
one of the things that you just said
that's very important is that it's
attractive to compassionate
intellectuals people that without really
looking at what the potential for these
these laws and regulations what the
negative potential for them is that the
the underlying inclination to lean
towards that is that you you you care
about people and then you you want
people to be okay and yeah well you're
kind of treating them like they're your
children and and I don't mean that in an
entirely sarcastic manner it's
reasonable in some sense to treat other
people like people that you love
although it's not reasonable in in very
many other ways which is why you don't
invite every stranger on the street to
come and live with you in your house I
mean everybody puts up boundaries and
you have to do that but and people tend
more than we ever expected and I've done
a lot of research and this in my lab
people do tend to vote and think their
temperament a lot more than than anyone
really realizes and and if you're kind
and that's your highest virtue then you
tend to treat people like their kin
because that's what kind means right
it's it's an extension of the word
and but that doesn't work well in large
groups you need other principles and so
you look at something like the idea of
equity which is equality of outcome
rather than equality of opportunity on
the surface of it it seems perfectly
reasonable to say well if every resource
isn't distributed absolutely equally to
every group then the system is unfair
and on the face of it that's a
reasonable proposition but it falls
apart under minimal examination so
here's something to think about for for
everyone who thinks that equality of an
outcome is a good idea it's like why the
hell are you striving for anything then
because the reason anyone strives to
better themselves or to develop a skill
or to move forward in life at all is to
produce inequality you're trying to rise
above the mediocre masses every time you
make an effort at anything and so
everything that we associate positive
movement forward to your positive
motivation is actually an attempt to
render the world more unequal now you're
rendering it on we equal in a just way
right because we might say well if you
work really hard you deserve an unequal
outcome well yeah unless you want people
to stop working hard and that was the
old joke in the Soviet Union you know
they pretend to pay us we pretend to
work so it's so it's it's it's so
thoughtless that that's that's the
problem well it's also extremely
annoying for people who've worked really
hard and who've made the requisite
sacrifices to become successful along
some dimension to have that immediately
attributed to their oppression yes and
it's not it's not obvious that that's
something we want to do it's like for
the social justice warrior types out
there who might be listening it's like
do are you really willing to say that
every single person who's accomplished
something has done that as a consequence
of oppression that's again with the
Soviets claimed with regards to the to
the successful peasants in the nineteen
in the just before the 1920s it's like
well the peasants weren't emancipated
they were serfs until about thirty years
before that they were serfs they were
basically slaves and some of them had
clambered up to the point where maybe
they owned their Hut and a cow
when could you don't employ someone well
the Soviet claim was well that's all
theft you got that all because you're an
oppressor and so then the Soviet
intellectuals went into the villages and
just imagine how this happened so
imagine a village a small town where
everyone knows everybody and there's
maybe 1020 people there who are
moderately successful ok and so you can
imagine that those 20 people have like a
hundred enemies at the bottom of the
socio-economic distribution useless
horrible people who are jealous and
resentful about the fact that these
people have been successful ok so now
the intellectuals come in and say
property is theft success is oppression
and then they looked for the people in
the village who are willing to move
against those 20 successful people while
those guys at the bottom those hundred
resentful jealous murderous people at
the bottom they're just waiting for an
opportunity to go kick down some doors
and that's exactly what they did in the
1920s and as I said they wiped out all
their productive peasants and then six
million Ukrainians starved to death
they had posters the Soviets produced
posters in the 1930s that said
essentially don't forget it's wrong to
eat your children so whoa yeah whoa
there's nothing about the Soviet there's
nothing that you can imagine that's
horrible enough so that it matched the
reality of what happened in the Soviet
Union between 1919 and 1959 and you know
the West knew about this too early
Malcolm Muggeridge in the 30s was
documenting for England for the very
English newspapers exactly what was
going on in the Soviet Union
bloody intellectuals didn't admit it to
the mid-70s you know with the exception
of people like George Orwell
[Music]